hello everyone I'm Franco from
astrazeneca I nice on her side today I
would like to share with you about the
law and regulation or laboratory animals
in China here is the main topics of
today mainly focus on selling parts the
first lady's laboratory animal industry
in China another in this part are you
talking about the history and some
developmental of laboratory animal
industry in China and then the framework
of level 2 animal administration
followed by Halloween D is the relevant
laws and regulation in China and also
the gb and TV and quality control in
China in the TV and is the China this is
a stand for this is of China spenders
mean TD is a Chinese p also the level
terminal using breeding license I'm the
microorganism water food dining facility
parameter the last part is a animal
welfare in China
let's go to the first part the first one
is the label animal industry the first
appearance of laboratory animals in
China is a nineteen eighty nineteen
eighteen went out to chanting T Brady
miles from experiment but until after
curve after until nineteen eighty-two
the first national news conference take
place in lanky TIG please October 988
the laboratory animal an institution
regulations I was released and I'll DC
on the same bra 1989 and 87 the
laboratory animal quality control
regulation was released based on the
statistician for 2008 780 key engaging
in about animal industry of for 300
unison Christ
he is the free worker for the motor
animal administration all the laboratory
animal industry although everything was
a was the ministry cheetah by the
Ministry of all science and technology
short for most yeah d ye into three
parts the first is a National Quality
Center which is a which is
responsibilities or animal policy
monetary and control the 2nd Para is the
Prince of ministry of science and
technology which is responsible for
license issue and renew the license are
including the animal use license and
breeding license the last is the last
car is the china association of
laboratory animal science which is the
responsible for training the training
scientists the training supervisor
training the animal technician he is a
relevant law laws and regulations in
China the including three parts the
first is a low on a regulation including
the laboratory animal on a ministry team
which was issued by Muslim which was
mentioned previously then the provincial
regulation or administration of
laboratory animals which was issued by
pressure people congrats and laboratory
animal quality control which was issued
by Sri menstruation together also there
are pressure regulations including the
pressure regulations and guidelines and
policies which was governed by the
pencil comment the last one is the TB
which means the standards including the
national standard and a mystery no
standard and a precious land and
products render TV are pre very
important part rule in China he almost
including Qaeda in Qaeda install the
everything actually everything in the
level animals garden how to do and what
to and to comply with the laws in 1994
the Chinese Pfiesteria for techniques
technicial supervision issued a series
of national standard 47 of which applied
to laboratory animals in 2001 revealing
of those studies standards increased the
number to 83 in in two thousand file
national national technical committee or
laboratory animal science of sanger
ization administration of china was
established under center set up 93
standard for level two animal quality
control this deuce deuce d be covering
fire area including micro biology
genetics full staff and SPF chicken in
additional other entities such as the
ministration of medicine medicine
agriculture hair was slicked said
laboratory animal quality standards and
some of the some of the more developed
the print prints prints prison cities
like Beijing Shanghai Guangdong and
Jiangsu pimples their own standards as
to some large company or injured in
practice for their products most
subsidies are substantially issued a
guideline that ETO prettier for the
reveal pro
preventional person provincial level to
animal monitoring center the task of
foods in jersey to employee employee
research on casting quality trained
technicians can recycle site inspection
an annual review of a prince or
laboratory animal monitoring center
under abhijeet teach dispute monitoring
results so quality wonder network
comprises six the National Center
carrying microbiology personality
genetics has solid phys lab environment
and facility here as well as 26 pressure
center in 23 produce the next one is
about the laboratory animal use reading
license all the ecgs must pay attention
to hear it this is must must be
accredited under being beaten a beating
a breeder or user license before handy
before handling the water animal
producing laboratory animal under
released products the substantial sum
the substance temporary regulation on my
management of laboratory animal science
most in 2001 details requirement and
procedures for license license
application review under supervision
basically in China everybody want to use
the laboratory animal use license you
use must be catch the license this
license was issued by the government
under renewed every five years but the
atomic normally is randomly inspector
inspector the Institute Institute
annually
licensed was a register by most under a
ministry TDI pd SPS a way to wrigley the
license holder annually through the site
visitor report in the following part I
will generally introduce the requirement
of for the water animal industries in
China first i would like to introduce i
would like to instruction about the
microorganism water food banning
requirement the first is a laboratory
animal level terrain more clarification
based on the microbiology this is a 4
did for category first is a conventional
and then is a clean read and lsdf greed
lust is a germ-free grid mouse and red
are for breeding and used must can
confirm to reach 2 3 and 4 guinea pig
chemist and rabbit can be maintained in
any of the Creator talks monkey are
subject to conventional and the SPF grid
each grid of animal must fulfill the
requirement of a national standard
drinking water commissioner animal must
have a drinking water for the scene
hygiene standard test for human use
higher a higher grade animal should be a
supplier will sterilize the drinking
water SPF animals pretty barrier
facility careful filter and a purified
water from drinking water machine diet
according to the regulation laboratory
animal must be filled with certified
formular diet is preparing to three
design movies the any meal with padding
pet or protein a full field staff
vegetables or fruit for animal food must
be adequate enough fresh many companies
that produce tied for large animal
these diffusion are required to the
beach in laboratory more product supply
license nutrition nutrition standard for
laboratory animal nutrition also covers
the competition and quality of food for
different strain and used like accruals
and reproduced maintains and a special
diet need penny the set you stupid is
that bearings material should be treated
according to the requirement of
different grid of laboratory animal
under mostly clean dry non-toxic
non-toxic on the free of insect and
infectious agents and closings the
national standard for the laboratory
laboratory environment is this that all
type of bedding material should be
sterilized with high pressure on all
eurovision basically the food water and
food water and bedding is the i think is
a steam with global with the
international standard in the following
are we on the spin cycle time has been
some time to share with you on the
facility parameter requirement very well
I really want to guess the animal use
license must be compared with this TV
the bottle anymore requirement of
environment and housing facility this TV
was is detailed detailed everything on
the facility design and a facility
requirement here at least some example
the frosty is the facility location like
the distance to people iowa area with
sexual and the general requirement
including the corridor widest and the
tall size et cetera and the support area
quarantine story shower
etc and also the wistar disposal
including liquid solid biohazard animal
cookies what food pairing an animal
transportation also I detailed the
parameter C and mop acidity in this GBP
this DVD released the least the animals
like us for parts the first is a red
mouse and then hey mr. guinea pig talk
rabbit non-human promised cat mini pig
and cheeks mouse on the red mouse and
the read-only Houston very arise later
the temperature requirement is 22 26
similar with the barrier and the
isolator hi mr. guinea pig but the in
conventional conventional surroundings
the hi mr. guinea pigs are 18 to 29 for
large animals like a dog range non-human
primates catch mini pigs the
conventional temperature is a 16 to 26
and in Perry a nice return 22-26 for
cheek is a 20 to 26 as an extra fracture
of temperature is below 4 degrees
centigrade and the humidity is 40 to 70
for a change powers is in general di
over 10 times per hour but for
conventional conventional chemist and
guinea pig and a conventional larger
animals three also eight for the animal
trio and mortuary or in the cage that is
a below 0.2 meter m/s for an ammonia is
a pillow 15
ppm and a pressure in the pressure for
the very area there is a team but in the
isolator and in isolator and the faces
of 50 for the this quarter this hip area
is a should be small than three cfu the
isolator is none noisy is a musty below
60 works in the work area should be over
200 and in the animals in rulings
animals is to 15 to 20 and for large
animals 100 to 200 for cheeks is fire to
1030 night opening is at a landfill the
last part is animal welfare the Carolina
humane treatment of laboratory animal is
a country first abroad and more fair
regulation which was issued by mostly in
2006 this guideline require each
Institute establish I cook through see
and evaluate always best of all his
animal care a news program in another
world in China every every level animal
Institute must held I cook whatever ye I
from a cuticle company all academic
units it effective measures should be
taken to protect laboratory animal from
injury hunger thirsty this comfortable
fair disease and a pain ensure that they
receive the good husbandry and winery
carrying comfortable environment have
access to this bar food stuff and water
of sufficient her point quality and
quantity to maintain the healthy and
perform neutral behavior
the facility and environment master
provide the animal here we are no
psychology needs the pellet and this
should distressed our particular focused
on the guideline which is called which
is which call for adherence to the three
hours during the iris teaching every
speech of animal experiment after the
experiment animals should be utilized
according to a keen-eyed upon the
principle and the first appearance on
such creative internal policies
basically the requirement of burning
food and microbiology and facility I
think he's a very similar with
international standard the government
has established over several years the
government has his cabbage a series of
four regulation standards to ensure the
quality of laboratory animal and related
activities and those policies and there
is limitation has stimulates the
development of less in China China has
been weaker effort to achieve
international stand for is a live animal
facility and research laboratory animal
ins to be a world-class research in the
new in near future currently more than
40 Chinese institutions was acredita
party like and the more and more
research institutional pharmaceutical
companies around the world looking to
look into China poor investment
investment opportunities and more
release the business ah but this all i
want to say today do you have any
question